à regarder le ciel la sécheresse du
carême semble bien loin pourtant ses
conséquences se font encore cruellement
sentir aujourd'hui comme ici au quartier
manie bas à case-pilote cet apiculteur
met en boîte
ces dernières bouteilles avant livraison
de ses points de vente après il n'y aura
plus une seule goutte de miel dans ses
cuves en 14 ans de métier pour lui c'est
du jamais vu
ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
connu tel carême et sur les 28 ou chez
quand j'ai su la martinique dix pages
c'est sur toutes les communes un peu
yako prêcheur que j'avais pu récolter un
petit peu de miel de saint sacrement
ben comme audi comme c'est écrit dessus
le 14 mars
tout est vide il ya eu des floraisons
pas de monter d'un hectare parce que le
sol est trop sec et donc nous emplit
culture on n'a pas pu écouter les
abeilles sont forme par contre on a
utilisé cette période où il ya eu quand
même pas mal de pollen pour faire de la
multiplication de l'élevage de rennes
franchement augmenter le cheptel encore
en investis en bons mais sans savoir sur
vraiment pouvoir rentabiliser
pourtant cet apiculteur professionnel
plusieurs fois primée pour la qualité de
son miel possède tout de même 800 ruches
de quoi assurer en principe une
production régulière à cette période de
l'année
en temps normal g9 miel différent et
tout mais mature attire son plein je
commence à stocker pour la période de
disette qui va commencer aussi un
mauvais temps on va partir de septembre
octobre novembre jusqu'en février mme
ans sans récolte pas de stock et son
stock pas de revenus les quelques pluies
de ces derniers jours vont peut-être
relancer la production mais le manque à
gagner lui est irréversible aujourd'hui
j'ai déjà fait
à peine qui incarne chuck jeu devrait
produire normalement
déjà que je devrais déjà avoir récolté
alors il reste encore quelques mois
avant les mauvais temps avant
l'hivernage et la période difficile pour
les abeilles
donc maintenant je suis pas devin je
verrai je verrai il aura suffi de
quelques gouttes de pluie pour les voir
apparaître aujourd'hui les espoirs de
cet apiculteur sont tournés vers ces
fragiles bourgeons de fleurs